cities now are developing in ways that
are quite different from cities of 100
and 200 years ago cities are growing at
an incredibly fast rate 50 years ago we
had two mega cities of 10 million and
right now we have 19 mega cities another
30 years are adding about another 10
mega city so the rate at which these
cities are forming is very fast it's
unprecedented not only are these cities
developing on primary cultural land but
they're also expanding to forests and
wetlands and other natural ecosystems
the development of these cities
completely changes and modifies the
local hydrology and the local land cover
which has huge implications for things
like regional and local climate
Karen sedo is an associate professor in
the urban environment at the Yale School
of Forestry and environmental studies
her research has revealed that cities
are not only affected by their
environment they shape it shen jen is
interesting in part because it is the
place that the Chinese government
focused on as the laboratory for
economic policies and so shen jen was
the first special economic zone in all
of China and what that means is in the
late 1970s the central government of
China identified Schengen as a place
where it would test market based
policies so over 30 years the population
of the Pearl River Delta has really
exploded shen jen has gone from a small
fishing village to one of the global
manufacturing hubs and certainly one of
the major manufacturing hubs of China
and the population of the Pearl River
Delta has gone from about 8 million in
the early 70s 1973 to more than 50
million today soaring skyscrapers are
not only changing their surroundings
they're changing the climate cities are
definitely affecting their local climate
research on this has actually shown that
cities have a big impact on their local
climate through the materials that are
used in cities the use of different
materials whether it's concrete the loss
of vegetative qualities the loss of
vegetative cover completely transforms
the local hydrology and the local
climate system cities are shaping their
environment and shaping their climate
and I think one of the big unknowns as
we under the 21st century is on the
whole how will cities not only change
their local climate both in terms of
precipitation and temperature but how
will many cities actually affect more
regional and even global climate
worldwide cities are expected to absorb
two billion more people by 2030
professor Seto believes environmental
sustainability is crucial to urban
design there's a huge challenge ahead in
terms of providing infrastructure
sure energy water sanitation for all of
these new urban dwellers and at the same
time there's a huge opportunity as well
in terms of developing these cities in a
much more sustainable way clearly if we
look at globally most of the co2
emissions worldwide come from cities and
come from urban activities most of the
world's agricultural production goes to
feed people in urban areas and people in
cities car production transportation
energy demand is why people in cities so
we change the way we develop cities so
that people can walk around for their
needs and they don't have to drive there
actually will have a huge impact
potentially on energy demand
infrastructure demand water needs energy
needs while professor sedo's research
establishes that mega cities are
modifying their own environment more
research is needed to determine what
role global climate change is playing in
the process and so we need significantly
more research to try to understand how
as cities expand how do they affect
temperature how do they affect
precipitation do cities induce rainfall
to cities create dryer and climates and
how does that interact with global
patterns of climate change so on the one
hand you have global climate change
happening and you have cities modifying
their own climates and there's very
little understanding about how these to
interact so I think that's an area where
we need a lot more research and is very
very important for more information
about the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies visit environment
yale edu
you